[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild es ist der 19 juli 2021 in
Oranienburg in Brandenburg die
Temperaturen sind hoch der Himmel ist
blau Sommer in Deutschland unmittelbar
neben dem kleinen Stadtteil
Friedrichstal erstreckt sich ein großes
Waldgebiet Birken und Kiefern ragen in
die Höhe die Blätter und Felder sind
saftig grün immer wieder funkelt die
Abendsonne durch die nah beieinander
stehenden Bäume und hier mitten im Wald
gibt es einen verlassenen Ort ein
sogenannter Lost Place eine alte
Funkstation der Nazis Deckname
karoas die Natur macht sich das
Betonbauwerk immer mehr zu eigen der
Zugang für Privatpersonen ist strengst
verboten im Inneren des Bunkers liegen
Steine Schutt und Überbleibsel von
übermütigen die sich trotz Verbots in
den Bunker trauen um diesen eben zu
erkunden so auch zwei Männer an diesem
Juliabend gemeinsam nähern sie sich dem
Eingang des halb zerstörten funkbunkers
eine jeur einen halben Meter hohe und
breite Öffnung sie zücken ihre
Taschenlampen um das Innere besser
erkennen zu
können und machen dann mitten den Ruinen
der Funkstation eine grausame Entdeckung
die Männer entdecken den leblosen Körper
einer jungen Frau es ist Bianca
[Musik]
s Bianca s Tod erschüttert in diesem
Sommer 2021 eine ganze Region im Nazi
buunker karoas wird die damals
26-jährige von Kurt l brutal
niedergestochen wieso musste sie sterben
und was ist über ihren Killer bekannt
das erfahrt ihr in unserem Fall bei
tator Deutschland ich bin Tony Haier
schön dass ihr heute wieder mit dabei
seid und ich bin Mirko Kasimir hallo
zusammen im Sommer 2021 arbeitet Bianca
s als Altenpflegerin sie hat einen
fünfjährigen Sohn aus einer früheren
Beziehung mit diesem und ihrer
Großmutter lebt Bianca in einer Wohnung
in
Oranienburg es ist der 15 juli
2021 den Vormittag verbringt Bianca mit
Freunden in Berlin mit der S-Bahn fährt
Sie zurück nach Oranienburg Aufnahmen
einer Überwachungskamera zeigen die
26-Jährige an diesem Donnerstag am
Bahnhof in Oranienburg Bianca schiebt
ihr Damenrad auf dem Gepäckträger ist
ein Kindersitz angebracht die 26jährige
ist sommerlich angezogen sie trägt eine
weite Hose Flipflops und ein weißes
T-Shirt auf dem Hakuna Matata steht vor
dem Bahnhofsgebäude verabschiedet sich
die 26-Jährige von ihrer Freundin
Sabrina bianc sagt sie müsse zum Arzt
Küsschen links Küsschen rechts dann
steigt Bianka auf Ihr Fahrrad und fährt
los es ist das letzte Mal dass Sabrina
Bianca lebend sehen wird um 14 Uhr
erscheint Bianca nicht zu ihrem
Teammeeting bei der Arbeit auch Biancas
Sohn wartet vergeblich um 16 Uhr vor der
Kita auf seine Mutter Biancas Angehörige
beginnen sich zu sorgen starten wenig
später eine private Suchaktion und
Posten in den sozialen Medien vermissten
Anzeigen der 26jährigen
am Samstag zwei Tage nachdem Bianca
zuletzt gesehen wurde geht dann auch
eine offizielle Vermisstenanzeige bei
der Polizei ein die Ermittler suchen mit
einem Großaufgebot nach der jungen
Mutter setzen dabei sogar Mantrailer
Hunde ein leider
vergeblich und dann vier Tage nach ihrem
Verschwinden die grausame Entdeckung die
ihr bereits zu Beginn dieser Folge
gehört habt zwei Männer finden Bianca
tot im verlassenen naziunker nur wenige
Kilometer v ur Bahnhof
entfernt schon kurz darauf sind die
Einsatzkräfte am Tatort sie sperren das
Gebiet weiträumig ab keine 100 m vom
naziunker entfernt finden die Ermittler
Biancas Fahrrad im Wald schnell steht
die Frage im Raum ob Bianca vielleicht
von ihrem Mörder auf dem Waldweg
abgefangen
wurde tagelang kommt die Polizei mit den
Ermittlungen nicht voran sie wendet sich
an die Öffentlichkeit veröffentlicht die
überwachungskameranahmen die Bianca am
Bahnhof zeigen und bittet um Hinweise
und dann die
[Musik]
Wendung schauen Sie auf diese exklusiven
Aufnahmen Polizisten führen einen jungen
Mann ab in handschellm ja der Mann den
wir hier sehen soll Bianca s ermordet
haben am alten naziunker bei oranenburg
der Mann ist dringend tatverdächtig und
damit herzlich willkommen zu den bildl
News hier am Morgen am 27 juli 12 Tage
nach ihrem Verschwinden wird Biancas
Exfreund Kurt l von Zivilbeamten der
Mordkommission in seiner Wohnung
festgenommen und
abgeführt bei seiner Festnahme trägt der
29jähriger ein rotes T-Shirt eine
schwarze Cargohose und Handschellen sein
Blick ist ernst wie sich später
herausstellen wird hat Biancas bekannte
Lian s den Ermittlern den entscheidenden
Tipp
gegeben Werbung so hier ist jetzt mal
ein Buchtipp angesagt oh das ist eine
gute Idee ich suche nämlich noch
Weihnachtsgeschenke ich auch mein lieber
und ich bin passenderweise auf eine
coole krimmy Reihe gestoßen oder jetzt
machst du mich aber neugierig na sag mal
an ich schreib gleich mal mit also alle
Märchen Enden gut alle Märchen
Enden nee Stopp das ist nicht der Titel
aber was würdest du denn zu diesem Satz
sagen alle Märchen Enden gut na ja den
halte ich eher für ein Gerücht das
stimmt doch gar nicht dass alle Märchen
gut enden genau das ist eine Lüge und da
sind sind wir beim Titel Rotkäppchen
lügt heißt das Buch und mit dieser Lüge
beginnt der Auftakt einer Thriller
Trilogie von Bestseller Autor Elias
Haller der kommt aus Moment Moment
Moment warte warte von dem habe ich
gehört der ist Polizist oder und der
kommt aus meiner alten Heimat Sachsen er
kommt aus Chemnitz glaube ich und er hat
Bücher geschrieben über einen Kommissar
namens Donner Erik Donner genau sehr gut
du bist gut mir Hall arbeitet seit 20
Jahren als Polizist und jetzt gibt es
eine Reihe mit der Sonderermittlerin
Nora rotmann vom Landeskriminalamt in
Berlin die stößt auf einen
Korruptionsverdacht rund um den früheren
LKA Präsidenten und dann bricht die
Hölle los wie ein blutdürstiger Wolf
zieht ein Killer durch die Hauptstadt
Berlin er fügt seinen Opfern
größtmögliche Schmerzen zu dabei
inszeniert er seine eigenen abartigen
märchenversion von Rotkäppchen denn rot
Käppchen haben wir ja schon festgestellt
am Anfang Rotkäppchen hat gelogen hey
Stefan das klingt wirklich sehr spannend
und nach einer guten Inspiration für
Tatort Deutschland das finde ich auch
also Fälle innerhalb der Polizei sollten
wir mal nach gucken hier noch mal zum
Mitschreiben Rotkäppchen lügt der Auftag
zur grimtrilogie von Elias Haller ist am
10 Oktober rausgekommen und wenn euer
Interesse jetzt geweckt ist holt euch
das Buch gerne bei Amazon oder klickt
einfach auf den Link in unseren Show
nototes
Werbung
Ende am Nachmittag des 15 juli sah die
junge Frau kurtell vor seinem Wohnhaus
mit Dreck und blutverschmierten Händen
der sonst so wortkage Kurt erzählte ihr
er sei in eine Schlägerei geraten er
gehe jetzt duschen und packe die
dreckigen Sachen in die Wäsche nach Kurs
Festnahme durchsuchen die Ermittler bis
in die Abendstunden dessen Wohnung vor
seinem Wohnhaus interessieren sich
Kriminaltechnik besonders für sein
Fahrrad bei bianas Tod muss viel Blut
geflossen sein am fahrradlener suchen
die Ermittler nach ihren
dnapuren Anfang Februar 2022 kommt Kell
in neuropin vor Gericht und damit auch
die grausamen Details dieser Tat an die
Öffentlichkeit wieso musste Bianca s
sterben wie wurde Kurt vom Freund zum
Exfreund und schlussendlich zum Killer
aber der nach Bianca und Kurt lernen
sich im März 2020 kennen schwebten sie
anfangs noch auf Volke 7 beginnt das
Paar sich bereits nach vier Wochen viel
zu streiten Bianca und Kurt trennen sich
immer wieder doch sie kommen nicht
voneinander los ihr Sex verbindet sie
wir hatten ja nur Theater immer Stress
wir machten Schluss dann ging der Terror
aber weiter sie kam wieder an meine
Wohnung klingelte Sturm dann wieder
Versöhnungssex so beschreibt kurtell vor
Gericht seine Beziehung mit Bianca für
Ihr Sexleben findet Kurt die Worte
liebevolles
foltern klingt nach einer toxischen onof
Beziehung im Juni 2021 wenige Wochen vor
Biancas Tod trennen sich Kurt und Bianca
wieder die beiden halten dennoch Kontakt
ja und treffen sich an diesem fatalen 15
Juli wieder nachdem sich Bianca von
ihrer Freundin verabschiedet radelt sie
los wie sich herausstellt hat Bianca
ihren Arzttermin abgesagt und trifft
sich stattdessen mit Kurt l das karoas
scheint an diesem Julitag nicht spontan
von kurtell gewählt worden zu sein wie
die Ermittlungen ergaben googelte er
bereits vor bianas und seinem Treffen
nach dem verlassenen nsbunker und
speicherte mehr als 40 Fotos des
betongebäudes auf seinem
Telefon um kurz nach ZR klettern Kurt
und Bianca in den Bunker im Inneren
Rauchen die beiden Zigaretten und
Trinken ihre selbst mitgebrachten
Getränke irgendwann zieht Bianca ihr
T-Shirt aus oder lässt es sich von kurel
ausziehen dabei sitzt die 26jährige
wahrscheinlich mit dem Rücken zu ihrem
Exfreund plötzlich greift Kurt laut
Anklage ein Stechbeitel also eine Art
Stemmeisen zur Holzbearbeitung und rammt
diesen mit einem ungeheuren Kraftaufwand
in bianas Nacken bianca hat keine
Möglichkeit der Gegenwehr Sie kppt
rechts
der Stich ist tödlich und Kur rammt
Bianca laut Anklage noch sechs weitere
Male den Stechbeitel in den Körper er
trifft ihren Hals ihren Rücken und ihre
Lunge auch diese Stiche wären tödlich
gewesen um 15:30 Uhr verlässt Kurt den
Bunker lässt bianas Leiche dort liegen
perfide Kur istu zum fachpraktiker für
Holzverarbeitung die 2,5 cm 10 cm lange
Tatwaffe die ist ein Arbeitswerkzeug
dass er ständig bei sich trägt am
Todestag von Bianca hat Kurt l aber
frei am nächsten Tag so ergeben die
Ermittlungen googelt Kurt l dNA Spuren
zerstören und tatsächlich lockt sich
kurz Handy am 18 Juli noch einmal in die
Funkzelle am Tatort ein ist er
zurückgekehrt um Spuren zu
verwischen all diese Schilderung sind
die bnisse der Ermittlungen denn Kurt
schweig zur Tat den ganzen Prozess lang
einem Gerichtsgutachter gegenüber
schildert kurz war unter anderem Bianca
am 15 juli getroffen zu haben sogar mit
ihr im Bunker gewesen zu sein er
behauptet jedoch unter einem Filmriss zu
leiden und keine Erinnerung daran zu
haben was im Bunker passierte seine
Erinnerung würde da einsetzen wie er
sich später mit blutverschmierten Händen
vor dem karoas wiedergefunden habe
mhm das klingt natürlich äußerst
glaubwürdig und genau aus dem Grund hat
er wahrscheinlich auch am selben Tag
noch gegoogelt wie man den arpuren
zerstören kann ja total auch der
Gutachter glaubt Kurt diese Version der
Geschehnisse nicht aber es ist nicht die
einzige wirre Aussage des Angeklagten
bereits zum prozessauftagt gibt Kurt
Einblicke in seine Gedankenwelt in seine
gruselige Gedankenwelt denn wie bereits
erwähnt schweig Kurt zwar zur t aber
nicht zu seiner Person er hört jetzt
einen Auszug aus dem Gerichtssaal in dem
kurz seine Version
schildert seit 15 Jahren folgt mir der
Sensenmann der ist immer da sie sein
Gesicht nicht er trägt eine schwarze
Kapuze Gesicht Arme und Beine sind von
einer Kutte bedeckt daraufhin fragt der
Richter Udo Lechtermann und der folgt
ihnen ja er ist die ganze Zeit da auch
hier im
Saal Staatsanwalt Mark Reichard fragt wo
ist er denn
jetzt der Sensenmann ist hinter mir hier
im Saal er tut nichts ich hab keine
Angst vor ihm noch einmal Staatsanwalt
Mark Reichard sind sie krank psychische
Beschwerden nein ich fühle mich gut ich
leide nur seit Jahren an Schlafmangel
keine nacht schlaf ich durch der Stress
mit
Bianca Hybride Wesen Mischungen aus
insektenartigen Spinnen und Untote mit
blauen Adern sie sind da immer wenn ich
Stress
habe boah also das ganz schön spooky
alles absolut nach knapp einem Monat
Prozess am Landgerichten europien soll
nun endlich das Urteil fallen Biancas
Freundin Sabrina die Person die das
spätere Opfer zuletzt sah hat eine klare
Forderung an den Richter dass er
lebenslänglich gar nicht mehr rauskommt
schon B Bianca jetzt und den klein war
er jetzt angetan hat dass die Mutter
nicht mehr da ist also da tut mir schon
der kleine sehr dolle weh also das dass
er nicht mehr da ist also für den klein
Sabrinas Forderung deckt sich auch mit
der der Staatsanwaltschaft auch sie will
eine lebenslange Strafe sprich
mindestens 15 Jahre Haft denn nach
Auffassung der Staatsanwaltschaft
handelt es sich bei biankas Tod um Mord
nicht um Totschlag um das zu verstehen
schauen wir uns einmal die Definition
von Mord genau an die findet man unter
Paragraph 211 im
Strafgesetzbuch demnach ist ein Mörder
wer aus Mordlust zur Befriedigung des
geschlechtstriebs aus habbgier oder
sonst aus niedrigen Beweggründen
heimtückisch oder grausam oder mit
gemeingefährlichen Mitteln oder um eine
andere Straftat zu ermöglichen oder zu
verdecken einen Menschen tötet und die
Staatsanwaltschaft sieht das Mordmerkmal
der heimtüke als gegeben an am
22.022022 fät der Richter das Urteil am
Landgericht neuropiin und Richter
Lechtermann verurteilt Kurt aber nur zu
zwfeinhalb Jahren Haft wegen Totschlags
die Urteilsbegründung lautet wie folgt
Kurt l habe Bianca in voller
Tötungsabsicht siebenm einen Stechbeitel
in Körper gerammt weil sie ihn genervt
habe und Kurt nicht fähig sei aus Streit
und Stresssituationen herauszukommen der
Richter glaubt Kurt nicht dass dieser
sich nicht an die Tat erinnern könne das
hätte eventuell zu einer milderen Strafe
geführt doch ob Bianca arglos und wirlos
im Bunker gewesen sei das könne das
Gericht nicht beurteilen wir waren nicht
im Bunker dabei so der
Richter okay also das war jetzt viel
Juristendeutsch mit drin noch mal klar
ausgedrückt ü der Richter ist zwar davon
überzeugt dass Kurt Bianca getötet hat
das Gericht so nach Auffassung von
Lechtermann kann jedoch nicht
beantworten ob Bianca die tödlichen
Stiche hat kommen sehen und ob Kurt
seine Tat bereits im Voraus geplant
hatte Bianca dafür also in den Bunker
gelockt hatte nur so würde das
Mordmerkmal der Heimtücke gelten und
dementsprechend eine härtere Strafe für
Kurt unmittelbar nach der
Urteilsverkündung geht die
Staatsanwaltschaft und Biancas Mutter
die als Nebenklägerin im Prozess auftrat
in
Revision und tatsächlich am 22 März hebt
der BGH also der Bundesgerichtshof das
Urteil auf das Landgericht hat
zahlreiche gewichtige Indizien nicht
berücksichtigt die dafür sprechen
könnten dass der Angeklagte also Kurt
die arlose Geschädigte Bianca in den
abgeschiedenen wehrmachtsbunker gelockt
hat um sie dort unter Ausnutzung stark
eingeschränkter Verteidigungs
Möglichkeiten zu töten eine andere
Strafkammer muss den Fall jetzt neu
aufrollen und erneut prüfen ob kurtell
nicht eben doch heimtükisch getötet und
damit gemordet hat bis es soweit ist
sitzt kurtell weiterhin in
Untersuchungshaft für Biancas Freunde
und Angehörige nimmt dieser Albtraum
seit mehr als zwei Jahren kein Ende aber
ein kleiner Hoffnungsschimmer ist dass
Kurt vielleicht doch lebenslang hinter
Gitter muss
ja wenn auch nur ein schwacher Trost und
damit sind wir am Ende unserer heutigen
Folge von Tatort Deutschland wir haben
mit unserer eigenen Berichterstattung
gearbeitet die vor allem von Matthias
lukaschwits recherchiert wurde außerdem
haben wir Artikel der MOZ genutzt bei
Anmerkungen Kritik oder fallvorschlägen
schreibt uns gern eine E-Mail oder eine
Nachricht bei Instagram wir freuen uns
von euch zu hören und bis dahin alles
Gute und bis zum nächsten Mal euer Milko
und eure
Toni die hat diese Folge von T
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei tatout
Deutschland